after a rocky month of political
posturing tough talk and even legal
action
the prime minister is today in the
driving seat of brexit talks
with both sides still at the table he
wants the deadlock to be unlocked this
month here we are
we're the biggest trading partner of the
eu their biggest
export market plus we've been a member
for 45 years
we want a deal like canada's we want
that one after the final official round
of talks the eu commission leader ursula
vonderlein phoned boris johnson to
unlock a way forwards
in a joint statement after they said
they'd agreed on the importance of
finding an agreement if at all possible
as a strong basis for a strategic
eu uk relationship in future but that
significant gaps remain notably but not
only
in the areas of fisheries the level
playing field and governance
they instructed their chief negotiators
to work intensively in order to try to
bridge those gaps
they agreed to speak on a regular basis
on this issue
what that means is more brexit talks lie
ahead so i hope that you have a
fantastic
conference over the next few days as the
tory party conference got off to a shaky
start this morning when it came to
technology
ministers are still talking tough on
brexit to the party grassroots but any
deal must be fair
and the days of being held over a barrel
by brussels are long
gone under the conservatives there's no
question
our government will control our
fisheries our parliament will pass our
laws and
our courts will judge them
but with gaps still on those key
sticking points this time
is time really running out they're not
issues that michelle barnier and david
frost can overcome by themselves
they require politicians to intervene
and allow for compromises because these
are areas where neither the uk or the eu
is going to get
exactly what it first wanted this was
when it was always going to happen this
was when the drama was always going to
sort of come to a head so in a way
despite all of the noise despite all of
the
the sort of misbehavior on you can on
the uk side
some would argue also on the eu side
none of this was unexpected
the prime minister and the eu may want a
deal
their tone may have turned but
uncertainty still hangs heavy
both sides are digging in for the final
straight ali fortescue sky news